now we begin with breaking news and the
US announcing a troop withdrawal from
northern Syria the Pentagon says up to
1,000 soldiers will be pulling out as
Turkish troops and their Syrian allies
continue their offensive to push into
Kurdish controlled towns in the latest
advance those forces say they've
captured so Luke the town is important
it'll ensure supply routes from Turkey
as the operation progresses Sunday has
seen heavy bombardments on other towns
near the border Ankara says forces have
now entered tell abuse and they say
they've taken control of raza Lane the
fighting is forcing more civilians from
their homes though the United Nations
says 130,000 people have been displaced
in a moment we'll cross over live to
Zana holder on the turkey-syria border
first to Rosalind Jordan in Washington
DC Rosslyn what more can you tell us
about this line on a u.s. withdrawal
from Syria well according to the defense
secretary Mike Esper who is appearing on
US television this Sunday morning he has
said that he consulted with US President
Donald Trump on Saturday evening and
after taking a look at the situation on
the ground a decision was made that
these forces would have to be moved out
of northeastern Syria here's more of
what my Kasper the US defense secretary
had to say we believe that the Turks now
intend to go further south and
originally expected and to go both west
and east which would increase their zone
from beyond a 30 kilometer depth and
nearly 440 kilometers wide at the same
time we've learned last 24 hours and it
looks like the SDF is cutting a deal
with the Syrians and Russians now which
is asdf those are the surface forces
very in Assyrian democracy forces
defense forces that's right they're
cutting a deal and now what we're facing
is US forces in a trapped between a
Syrian Russian army moving north to take
on the the Turkish army that is moving
south it puts us in a terrible position
and the protection and safety of our
servicemembers comes first to me
spoke with the national security team
yesterday we all talked on the phone I
talked to the president and he is
concerned and so last night he directed
that we begin a deliberate withdrawal of
US forces from the northern part of
Syria Syria now of course Sammy the big
part of my Casper's announcement which
was already getting him criticized to
his face on the Sunday public affair
shows was the idea that yes it's
important to protect US forces from
being caught in the crossfire as it were
but this is also a situation where
because US forces are pulling out the
Syrian defense forces are now having to
build a security alliance perhaps with
both Syria and with Russia and that the
defense secretary made a point of saying
well yes they were very important in
terms of fighting ISIL but we weren't in
northern Syria to protect the Kurds that
may get him even more criticism and by
extension more criticism for the US
administration in the decision to pull
US forces back from northeastern Syria
all right rosiland Jordan there thanks
so much let's take this now Suzanna
holder she's on the border of Turkey and
Syria and we're hearing Turkey making
new gains tell us how that's shaping up
on the ground zina
we're really fast-moving developments
the map of northeastern Syria is
changing in just the past few hours
northeast Syria was under the control of
the Kurdish led Syrian democratic forces
as well as US soldiers in the past hour
or so the SDF has been losing ground
they have a few fighters who are holding
up in Rasul Lane and in other areas but
a border the border 120 kilometers
stretch of the border line is
practically cleared from the SDF of
course the Syrian Kurdish armed group
the YPG forms the backbone of this group
so 120 kilometers from Roselyn to tell a
Viet Turkish led forces are also pushing
south they have pushed 30 kilometers on
a number of fronts the Turkish Defense
Ministry saying that they've reached the
strategic highway the m4 highway that
they're in control of that highway so
the 120 30 kilometer pocket of territory
that the Turkish military planned to
initially capture in this in this
operation seems to be almost a success
now we are hearing that the US forces
are leaving Northeast Syria altogether
they've withdrawn from Aissa
also on this 30 kilometer mark we're
getting reports that they were drawing
from members which is to the west so
basically they have really no presence
in in a lot of areas in the east of the
Euphrates so the question now is what
happens next president Erdogan in his
speech it was an unscheduled speech he
said our goal is to push 30 to 35
kilometers deep into Syria what he did
not say is how long that border line
will be then we heard the US Defense
Secretary say the four that we believe
the Turks want 480 kilometers of that
border so many unanswered questions on
what happens next how is the territory
going to be divided because if the Turks
stop at 30 kilometers and the SDF
remains in control of areas south of
that we have to also remember further
south are the Russians and the Syrian
government a very complex picture
on the ground but what it seems is that
at least the same there is an initial
understanding once 20 to 30 kilometer
territory right if the US is pulling at
least some of its forces out how is that
going to change the situation there well
the US forces they had a few hundred
troops but the very fact that they were
there this was territory under their
control in one way or the other they
were giving protection to the SDF and by
extension the YPG this is a very
strategic corner of Syria it is where
oil fields are located it is the
breadbasket of Syria more than one
player wants it there's also critical
supply routes that link Iraq with Syria
so a very strategic territory that all
sides want turkey says it needs to push
the YPG from the border for national
security concerns it wants refugees to
return the Damascus government for
example wants the territory to return
under its sovereignty Iran offering to
negotiate between the Turks and Damascus
in order to revive an old deal the Idina
agreement to provide security to Turkey
at the border so with the u.s.
withdrawing it no longer is a player and
this area is up for grabs for more than
one one player in the in this conflict
and caught in the middle of all this is
hundreds and thousands of people who are
now scared not knowing who their new
rulers will be all right so as a new
holder there thanks so much